to all the boys I love before blew up in
2018 yeah so how pumped are you for the
sequel I'm so stoked it's like holding
that secret in that we were gonna make a
second that third was the hardest thing
ever but I'm so excited and if you're a
fan of tall the boys and you watch the
first one I know that you're gonna love
the second and it's a really wonderful
like you continue to see her journey as
a young high schooler trying to figure
out love and and kind of balance these
new relationships so it's really really
fun I love it so the very first movie
ran what was it because I'm super
jealous they don't know oh the very
first movie then was x-men apocalypse
[Applause]
yeah like usually people's first movie
is like no one's heard of it like it was
like being just thrown into the deep end
it was like sink or swim right you're
like I'm this is make or break me I
might never work again but it was so
amazing and I was auditioning as a
second semester senior in high school
and I knew I was in the running for it
and then I got a call from my agents
like in the middle of class and you're
not supposed to have your phone but I
was like yo cuz if it's your agent
calling you pick up no matter what right
I don't and they were like are you
around anyone can we tell you some news
and I was like I'm around everyone that
I know and so I ended up walking out of
school and I stood underneath the great
American flag and I they told me I that
I booked it but that I couldn't tell
anyone until the press release came out
so then I had to go back to freaking
class being like and not freak out oh my
god oh my god yeah it's an amazing first
job thank you
see he's booking major movies in high
school and I'm sweeping hair I was
selling vacuums so we're celebrating all
the fields February has this Valentine's
Day so you have anybody special I do my
boyfriend Anthony the love of my life
yes I don't know what we're gonna do or
probably just gonna like stay at home
and just eat like we do best date ever
y'all heard well that's us okay yeah
look at this one that's my puppy Emmy
Emmys adorable I love your man but I
love yeah yeah yeah her Emmys a girl
yeah yes yes yes butyl as she we just
celebrated her one-year one years old
and when you're being with us because we
got our like five weeks and she knows
she knows that it's that it's her one
year because we woke up and I'm a little
sick so Anthony went and took her out on
her morning walk and she pooped in the
shape of a heart
now I would like to say that I have a
picture of the said that's impressive
and I could shut it really challenged
yeah I just wanted to know if you feel
like mm not the vibe please look away
but yeah the phone you have a photos of
heart poop of the boy if you wanna look
at our Gina you know I want to look at
the heart poop
[Applause]
yeah
that's actually very impressive
happy Valentine's Day you guys I mean
the only thing better is if she just sat
behind him was like yeah like after him
so speak speaking of loved ones though
you just wanted a big family trip right
I did yeah so I'm adopted from Vietnam
and my family and I have not been able
to go back yet since I was adopted when
I was a baby so just recently we went
back to Vietnam and we found the
orphanage where my parents got my
brother and I and we were able to yeah
we were able to go inside and the paint
hasn't changed the curtains haven't
changed like I was able to see you where
I spent like the first my first couple
of months on earth was a baby and being
there with my family it was like full
complete circle and I've never felt so
I'm so just just still and dropped in
and whole yeah I said you weren't gonna
Oprah me right now wow that was really
my gosh my kid I would cry right now it
was the best trip of my life and I'm so
happy that I was able to finally do that
randomly enough literally Vietnam is the
first place my little girl ever went out
like Mary I did an event there like
years in it was right when River and my
little five year
oh she's point it was the first place
ever she was like three months she's
like well who knows but yeah it was
Sebastian duty any family trips you know
we didn't go to Vietnam I know we go to
the zoo we went to the LA Zoo as far as
we got but that's very bold to take a
child on a that long of a flight yeah
I'll tell you what I was terrified
because you didn't want all those people
to hate you but like she didn't cry once
you know what I do you know what I don't
which I think it's a nice touch I think
you get on a plane I go around I pass
out chocolates to everybody
it's like bribery yeah so just in case
did the kid does cry people get a little
sweet cuz they look at you and they're
like can you do something like do you
think I like what's happening do you
think I was like
oh my baby loses it on the plane and
everyone hates me like you know like
what are you supposed to do anyway
Vietnam is a beautiful country yes I
mean that was what I was trying to yes I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this